when you get locked up are you like like
i mean when you're an artist of
notoriety like you are in the city like
is is your experience any different than
anybody else's yeah for sure uh first of
all when you
like in la county there's no there's no
jail like la county jail explain
period like that's
that's gonna make a man out you that's
if you if you you know i'm saying you um
walk in the main line in the blues like
when you first get there and they know
you're a pressure another notoriety
they're gonna like you know ask you if
you want to be on a celebrity road
that's that's high power
like you always got to escort with you
you want a single man cell you're not
with general population
uh you basically protect custody i'm not
going for that you know what i'm saying
uh i'd go for that just for the record
yeah no i'm saying i'm i'm saying i'm
saying uh uh
yeah yeah for sure sign me up for that
one yeah for sure sure i understand i
understand
but uh
just from my perspective coming from
already right like being there yeah yeah
you know what i'm saying it's just
like it won't stay right with my
conscience but
i say that to say
like like when you walk in the main line
you in that and you in the main part of
that l.a county jail wayside man central
you know what i'm saying it's real
they're going to test you you're going
to you know i'm saying you got to stick
it out how different